uh mitch mcconnell is the senate
minority leader
he um
is a pretty horrible guy
yesterday
during joe biden's state of the union
when joe biden talked about his job
creation record
mcconnell didn't seem to like it he just
looked comatose almost like he had bad
had some bad oysters uh before before
the event
he was given the opportunity yesterday
to actually condemn what donald trump
said about vladimir putin calling the
invasion of ukraine genius and calling
the invasion smart and he didn't do it
mcconnell's very willing to say putin's
bad but he won't condemn trump for what
he said
you've long been critical of president
vladimir putin was it a mistake for the
former president to praise putin that's
very savvy smart is ukraine strategy as
a genius
what president putin is
is a ruthless thug
who's just invaded
invaded another sovereign country
and killed thousands of innocent people
that's what president putin is so yeah
mcconnell sounds very very sick but what
he's saying
is
i'm not going to say anything about
donald trump when donald trump said
putin's savvy
genius smart for what he did putin's bad
but i'm not going to condemn trump and i
almost at this point wonder why because
trump regularly attacks mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell did appear on fox
yesterday and blamed joe biden for
what's happening in ukraine which is
another popular one among the right
speech tonight he goes into the chamber
this evening with a 37
approval number what do you think he
needs to do tonight in order to
galvanize the united states and to as
you said earlier uh make a big course
correction what did you mean by that
well look uh he
he's in this kind of shape because he
deserves to be in this kind of shape
raging inflation
uncontrolled border
in my view
too late to deter
putin and we've taken some of these
steps earlier this might not have
happened and the president's in a tough
position because he deserves to be in a
tough position now understand that you
really can't win with these people
because if joe biden and and remember
it's not just the us but if joe biden
and other european allies had started
the sanctions and the flight closures
and these things early
these are the republicans who under
trump were saying we should be getting
along with putin there's no reason for
unnecessary or extraordinary hostilities
with putin so it's a no win because if
biden had started these these moves
earlier
he would have been criticized for
doing too much too quickly and being
overly aggressive
now he's being criticized for not moving
quickly enough and these are just bad
faith actors that's that's the reality i
don't believe uh joe biden's response
has been perfect and i've criticized the
response where i felt that it needs
criticism but these are just bad faith
critiques now just for comparison again
i don't love the guy but just as a
comparison for a different type of
republican here was mitt romney asked
about biden's handling and he gives a
much more normal response
about biden has done some things well
it's not biden's fault that putin
invaded another country but you could do
better this is like a more normal
republican response i want to go back in
time a little bit senator do you think
it was a mistake for president biden to
rule out u.s troops on the ground
instead of trying to use what's known as
strategic ambiguity to deter vladimir
putin from invading in the first place
well there really wouldn't have been an
ambiguity we don't have the kind of
troop strength uh and and material of
war in the region to be uh to be a
serious threat at at that point uh look
the the uh
the bite administration has done some
things very well and some things not so
well the not so well side as they
continued the policy of prior
administrations not to provide the
defensive weapons ukraine needed that
was the mistake the positive thing was
sharing our intelligence with our allies
and combining
our efforts with our allies look we used
to be 40 of the world economy today
we're about half of that and and so for
us to have the kind of economic clout we
used to have back in the 50s and 60s and
70s we really do need to combine with
our allies and that's something
president biden has done extraordinarily
well so understand that that's sort of
like i know it's weird to hear that like
to some people that might be like well
that if you didn't know who it was you'd
be like that must be a democrat no
republican would say that joe biden is
actually doing things that well there
was a point at which more normal
republicans would say oh okay hey you
know what your criticism of biden isn't
a good one and here's why and joe biden
mitt romney explained that
on some things joe biden has done a
really good job
and here are the things i would have
done differently that at one point was
actually normal and for all of our
disagreements with mitt romney if romney
was the worst of the republican party
this country would be far better off
than with people like than we are with
people like mcconnell
bobert
green
cothorn gomer and all of these you know
gates and all of these other uh lunatics
so um it would be great
if we could go back in that direction
republicans aren't incentivized to do
that and case in point someone like mitt
romney is not a celebrity republican in
the sense that the ones that get
attention are the radical crazies the
ones that are willing to do things like
josh hawley did on january 6 2021 people
like ted cruz etc it's the cartoons and
uh i mean listen i'm not giving the
republican party advice the country
would be better off if romney was the
worst of the party sadly romney's the
best of the party not the worst of the
party
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping